looks like we're live yeah I think so
all right everybody everybody here Swede
we okay yeah hopefully I think I got the
don't you turn on that don't you turn on
that hold on it's not turning it off I
mean don't you do the time make sure the
volumes down cuz you always do the
volume thing and then I get distracted
cuz I hear my own voice bounce back at
me I've gotta reset that [ __ ] okay doing
like we're doing to live streams today
we're we were doing this one what's our
regular matinee show we have decided
like I said that we're gonna start live
streaming some of our regular episodes
as well and we decided to do this one as
a live stream so we will be doing that
tonight at 7:00 p.m.
yeah seven cent o'clock is gonna be a
good live stream you guys are gonna
enjoy it so make sure you guys show up
yeah we're doing I want to see something
like a flashbulb I want to see some
goddamn flash bulbs on them no I'm just
kidding three we're gonna do three cases
and I'll be I'll be loaded by times I'm
sure you probably will because it's
actually I was actually gonna do four
cases but then I thought no that's gonna
be way too long because she's trying to
bite off more than she can chew she does
this [ __ ] regularly well I'm going to
three cases I'm gonna do two cases next
you know shows trying to tries to push
like five hours long over the court
we're recording I have to stop it
Jenny you sure you want to do that case
how much time we got that this thing's
gonna be [ __ ] three hours long that's
what she does cuz you know I know her
yes well yeah so she's gonna do this I'm
paranoid about not having enough like
stuff to talk about even it's weird
because when we did the Italian serial
killer show I only had two cases stress
and then well yeah but that only ended
up being two hours that was emotional
landscape being a trained killer and I
said it's about love
I sent her link it's a it's 7:00 p.m.
Eastern Time yeah Knott central
like tonight we're gonna do the show
like I said we're gonna do three cases
like I said we're gonna do four but then
when I like three hours now three when I
was read no it's not three hours from
now it's this for now right no it's - oh
it's - you don't even know what time is
it's five hours about five hours from
now it's like holy crap I'm gonna be the
like a nap before that yeah like that
take an old man now I might take an old
lady that well just because I you know
and Saturday is kind of the only day
that I allow myself to sleep in but of
course I could sleep in because Pookie
found a roach yeah and she was killing
it this morning and was also trying to
wake us up like to tell us that she
found a roach and that we needed to take
care of the problem so it's like it's
six o'clock she was like she was like
banging around the house and everything
like that but at least she got it you
know she's a good girl like that but now
she kills the thing for dropping by yeah
I woke up this morning and Pookie I saw
her over there called smacking something
I said that must be a roach yeah she's a
big ol Palmetto bug yeah and she tried
to bite it but she knows that they're
nasty so she pulls back in the last
minute but no I'm not gonna bite it I
got a bite she wants to kill it but she
can't she just kind of bring herself to
bite it yes she doesn't hot she's a good
guard cat she doesn't let any of those
things come in yeah as soon as the Rocha
comes in if she sees it she cuz it rains
here and they can go right through the
sliding glass doors and then go right
underneath the door they try to get in
the house
yeah and they're [ __ ] mean yeah
they'll rare up and look at you and [ __ ]
as you approach them if they're healthy
yeah they're [ __ ] like like they're
on roids get away from me we're up like
a [ __ ] praying mantis yeah and you
know that's a badass Roach when you see
those things they're palmetto bugs
they're not like this ain't your knocker
they're [ __ ] big they're like the
size of a grasshopper yeah bigger than a
[ __ ] bigger than a cricket it's
pretty nasty
yeah they're bad yeah like reddish
Browns the thing that they have here in
the south man [ __ ] nasty that's why
it's and this is one of the things it's
like the one of the worst things and the
worst things about the place it's how
our
like all the [ __ ] bugs and they I'll
just eat a palmetto tree alive yeah well
they make nests and then yeah you pull
the bark off the tree in the thousands
yeah
that's we had that happened at my
grandmother's house because she was
wanted to take that tree down so it was
dying and my dad went out there and I
was like there's gonna be a big mess in
there ya know it was awful
yeah that's this like I was like oh I
need to shower forever yeah the good
thing about him is that they're so big
it's hard for them to infest a house
because they can't hide yeah and I mean
and and when you got when if they ever
kind of take root you know you got a
problem so you can fight them yeah the
ones he is that are hard to fight it as
little tiny ones you can barely see yeah
like I said when one gets in our house
yeah intense if she she is she'll jump
on it and kill it yeah movie review
today this was actually a really good
one this was another shutter original or
shutter exclusive I'm not really sure
like if there's a difference between
those two things I don't know if like
shutter puts up the money or if they're
just showing him or whatever this is
actually one that I think it just came
to shutter June 25th or June 27th so
very very recently or June 27th that's
today so I guess it was the 25th I don't
know what it is either
this is a Belgian / Dutch co-production
it's a zombie movie and it's called
yummy and this one's got the Tom Seal of
Approval I really like this movie it was
well yeah it's like I do you know I
don't like to put too much stock in
because I don't know if you have shudder
like they have little skull ratings like
you know people can write the titles or
whatever and you know sometimes I the
ratings it's like sometimes the movie
only has like three skulls but then I
really liked it sometimes it has five
skulls and I'm just kind of like man
whatever and sometimes like people like
give bad reviews this one had five and
deservedly so it seemed like a lot of
the people that comment or like talking
about for Arkham great it was this is
definitely one I know you know zombie
movies and there's a million of them and
people are probably like sick of seeing
zombie movies it's not really a zombie
movie I mean yeah kind of is boy
reanimate err yeah it definitely
only how to reanimate her vibe to it
it's like super super gross and like
super rough so if you're into gore or
just like funny like gore gags it's not
a comedy really although it had like a
lot of comedic moments I guess yeah
would you call it a straight-ahead
comedy I don't really think a straight
addcom what would you call reanimate or
a comedy yeah would you call from beyond
a comedy right I mean it's that tone
yeah it definitely does know that's the
that's the tone I like yeah because it's
in it it's gross it's got some [ __ ]
gross [ __ ] in there but it's
entertaining it's not really depressing
you were turning you off you're like
okay yeah and if funny [ __ ] happens in
and even though it's like horrible yeah
that dude's dick gets burnt off this
that like I said yeah just like made us
laugh and yeah and laugh yes so much a
situational humor the cool thing about
it too was that you know even though it
was funny and it was over-the-top and
stuff like that it definitely did like
the third act was actually like really
tension-filled you know what I mean
where it was like you were kind of
worried about you know it was like
exciting you were worried if they were
gonna like escape and you were worried
about that kind of stuff so basically
like I said this is a Belgian Dutch
co-production I think it premiered if
I'm not mistaken at South by Southwest
Film Festival sometime last year but it
just now came to streaming and here's
the setup of the story is this so
basically it's this girl named Alison
and her boyfriend Michael and Alison's
mom who I think her name is Sylvia and
they are driving to this real shiftee a
clinic in some unnamed Eastern European
country because she wants to get a
breast reduction yeah see this is the
thing about this this chick here man
she's got a [ __ ] body though [ __ ]
won't quit she looks like them one of
those Eastern European porn stars like
skinny girl with like a F cup and she's
trying to get a reduction yeah and her
boyfriends like kind of going along with
it she's like it's like that's what she
wants and she's like you know I'm
sick of people like lyrical birds my
back yeah yeah it always kind of stuff
is just you just you don't just like me
from a boobs do you know that constant
no of course not honey he's got a
[ __ ] ring and [ __ ] and that [ __ ] goes
on and the thing he there's another girl
at the at the clinic who looks pretty
hot and he doesn't quite give her the
ring because she's gonna lop them things
off so they've already built the tension
where you're trying to save the titties
because the titties are wrists and her
mom's with her and her mom's a whole
milk type you know I mean yet with the
same kind of build and she's like you
should appreciate what God gave you that
kind of she's going the mom is going to
get a facelift they're all here at this
chief facelift and I think a tummy tuck
or something
yeah want to get it but mom was looking
pretty good too you know I mean for for
a woman or 50s but you know she just so
they've already set it up to [ __ ] play
with a man's emotions okay from the very
beginning of this cuz the boobs are risk
[Laughter]
well that's what in a way that's what
move man I like a big full figure on a
woman I'm not a name those skinny women
like no matter that you gotta have some
female feminine build like strategically
deployed big legs but yeah so well the
thing about it and that's what I think
is so funny too that the reason this
movie is called Yummie is that not only
is it like a zombies and they're eating
people so they think human flesh is
yummy but also in the sense that it's
kind of about I mean you know the kind
of backdrop of it is this you know
clinic where everyone's trying to like
improve themselves it's like you know
trying to look you know as beautiful as
possible and in a way she's kind of like
trying to go against that because like I
she has like these really big knockers
and like a really like a figure that a
lot of women would like to have but it
did you know she doesn't like it it
doesn't fit so she wants to get rid of
it and so there's that whole tension
with her with the boyfriend and then
they meet this other dude like you know
that as it goes on like they meet other
people you know other doctors other
patients and everything and they start
to like the boyfriend starts to think
that maybe this place is like not a
place they should be because like I said
they don't say what country this is
settings just in Eastern Europe
somewhere I'm not sure if this is true
but I was like listening to another
horror channel reviewing this and the
woman on there said that the Eastern
European language that the doctors and
nurses are speaking to each other is not
a real language so I guess you made up
like like it's a variation but it's not
like a real language because I think the
thing about this okay so like I said
it's it's largely a Belgian movie so at
the beginning you know most of the
characters are speaking to each other
what do they speak there it's French and
there's like [ __ ] five different men
or you know or something like that so or
whatever and there's no hours for the
English and the English the English
accents can get the accents in English
are quite strong I couldn't understand a
lot of the English in it it doesn't
really matter though a lot of yeah this
is a very visual yeah the you me it's
like you do kind of need to know some of
the stuff but like I said so a large
part of this is actually in English yeah
um you know but like you said some of
the people's accents are stronger than
others so you know whether you can like
determine what they're saying but like I
said it's hugely important but when the
doctors and nurses speak to each other
in this Eastern European language which
I think is called Balkan to use or
something like that like I said it's my
feet scratch harder ah strategize all
right and can't reach so this so they
don't subtitled that yeah which I
thought was like a good move because
it's on it makes it like you're at this
[ __ ] clinic and you're at the mercy
of these doctors and nurses and you
don't know what they're saying and
nobody is so so it's putting you like in
the same boat as the protagonist yeah
but when they all speak to each other
they usually speak you know English if
it's something else that has to be said
now these zombies are not there there's
ah
I guess but there's zombies in the way
that like they're zombies in the
reanimate er they're [ __ ] around with
some kind of stem cell research
yeah and they had one kind of mutant
pace patient that they had they were
experimenting on right and she was dead
but she was came back to life and the
dudes accidentally let it go
because it's a hot chick mouth but she
was in trouble thought she was in
trouble right Chandan he doing about it
right there was like an outbreak and you
know they got one thing about it is that
it's got a good-looking cast this guy
it's got guys for the ladies to look at
and it's got a bunch of good-looking
girls in it so it is got a good-looking
cast and then some crazy [ __ ] happens in
it and there's just such great that's
great like I said you're into gore gags
like Stuart Gordon type stuff or like
Dead Alive or something like that you'll
probably love this movie because it is
so goopy and just so bloody they've got
this one guy in there I don't was he
German or was he French was which guy
the the guy that works there the orderly
he had white hair he was kind of like a
goth type guy I figure out if that guy
works there or if I think he was working
there he would maybe it was like it
orderly but he was yeah but he was also
like a junkie yeah sneaking all of them
stealing all the drugs all the morphine
and taking it was making a move on dudes
girlfriend and saying sideways [ __ ]
behind her you know no meaning [ __ ]
it's just you just got a sense because
of the tits okay yeah that's all he
really gave ya yeah actually you know he
was trying to save them too
everyone was like no everybody was like
what are you doing well like I said that
so that was the whole thing here's
nothing they're not real
it's the falsies you can tell they're
falsies inside and inside of it yeah but
I mean but they're pretending I mean in
the movie they're saying they're real
yeah she's got falsies on well cuz I
mean that was the whole point of the
characters that I mean and the my can
tell they won't know they did not have
the wait well in the and the body that
she has
is I don't think I've ever seen anyone
with those proportions natural oh I have
you have yes it's it's unusual that's
unusual it's a Chinese genetic genetic
being that small and large I mean I'm
sure it does happen
yes it's very unusual like firmage
remember that remember the pictures that
Eastern European girl from the 90s she
was sucking hugeinjapan she didn't
really do porn but she did kind of just
nudes yeah and she was built about like
that jazz skinny with oh man GG yeah
yeah sorry you were amazed
yeah damn it's very rare but yeah so the
great thing about this is [ __ ] there's
just [ __ ] great [ __ ] I mean the
liposuction gag just these zombies that
are just like you know there's pus and
blood and [ __ ] organs and I mean the
one zombie and I said she's on the
poster so it's kind of like not really a
spoiler but the one zombie with no legs
who's like eating her own the whole dick
thing like that whole sequence yeah cuz
there's a guy there I like that they had
like equal opportunity because there's a
guy there who at the clinic who was
apparently like some kind of famous
person or celebrity they don't really
say like what he's a celebrity or
anything like that but he is they're
getting a penis enlargement and after
all the [ __ ] goes down and the zombie
outbreak starts to happen he decides
that you know because he's probably
gonna die or whatever so he needs to
like hook up with this one chick who's
willing it's not like he's you know
doing it doing it like a do or
unwillingly or anything but they're
doing this [ __ ] and it's like the
funniest [ __ ] happens to this dudes
crotch and it's just like I don't know
it's just I laughed and laughed and
laughed and I was just so happy that
they went there with it and just did
this crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean another thing too I have to
mention and I I almost kind of wish they
had done more of this in the film which
is probably like my only criticism of it
but there's one
seen like later on where the boyfriend
is looking for the kids they get
separated or whatever and he's looking
for the girlfriend and he goes into this
big lab and there's all these jars in
there with like all these weird fetuses
and like weird like um you know animal
hybrid type of things and they come to
life like they're alive and one of them
gets out and it's like what what is it
is it like a fish frog it was it were a
Salim and it looked kinda like a big
salamanders it was like a big gecko
yes alum and ER and it's um they must
have been messing with it stem cells
yeah because it was still alive in that
jar and it was falling her and it was
about I'm like trying to but that was a
great egg in fact and it was big it was
the size of the [ __ ] turtle or a Gila
monster yeah yeah yeah and so it was
like it was kind of like running around
and it's like I don't know I'm not sure
how they did that I mean I'm imagining
there's a puppet it was a puppet but it
was a really really good puppet yeah and
um so I kind of wish they had done a
little bit more with the creatures but I
mean maybe I don't know I was gonna say
maybe they could do a sequel but I'm not
really sure I really sure if they could
do a sequel or not but I did like that
aspect of it and I kind of wish they've
done a little bit more that was like the
creatures and the jars and stuff and
them escaping because I really liked
that one little creature and they could
have done more with that but other than
that I mean I really liked everything
about this one it was really fun it was
really disgusting it was really actually
had tension at the end when you were
worried if they were gonna get out
it had an ending that I wasn't really
expecting I'm kind of glad that they
ended it the way they ended it yeah um
the ending was almost kind of like
something out of The Walking Dead
yeah only yeah kinda and yeah I like
that they didn't you know and maybe this
is like a spoiler alert but I kind of
like that they didn't end it like Oh
everything's gonna be okay yeah yeah you
know if they didn't end it Lena and she
basically it ends it's the beginning of
a damn global outbreak yeah but I like
to that they kind of ended it like in a
funny way it's kind of funny and then
it's kind of horrific at the same time
yeah um bunch of tragic comedy and [ __ ]
yeah
which I really liked I just liked the
whole tone of it and I really liked the
way it was shot like the cinematography
and everything I'm pretty sure the name
of the director is Lars de moi so this
might be his first movie I'm not real
sure or his first full-length movie I'm
not really sure correct me if I'm wrong
as knows they're asking if it's kind of
like kind of like rabid um rabid was a
lot more serious I guess this one is
more I wouldn't call it a comedy but it
definitely has a comedic tone to it it's
more like reanimate er yeah I would say
or maybe like Dead Alive not quite as
zany as that or as Gauri's I mean
nothing's as gory as dead alive but or
brain dead if you're in another country
but yeah that business said Brokeback
Mountain gave us our pyth game Zak okay
Zak they're talking about you man
because he just commented up here he
says ass and titties Thom they calls him
yeah it's like I think that was kind of
like that was another really cool thing
that I liked about this movie cuz I
think this might have been the only time
that I've seen a zombie movie that was
set in like a cheesy like a yeah like a
shady plastic surgery clinic so it was
kind of going into that whole [ __ ] too
with like yeah the whole thing about her
boobs and like yeah and the boyfriend
not wanting to say that he didn't want
her to get rid of the boobs cuz she
wanted to get rid of the boobs there was
like all this kind of tension about it
yeah the humor the humor is not PC which
I liked is kind of refreshing they're
just like a [ __ ] you know kind of a
throwback to some of the horror movies
you've seen the 80s where you know young
guys saw it would go see those moves cuz
there's gonna be a tats on them yeah you
know I mean that and it just had to be
in there and well in the 80s pretty much
every horror movie yeah yeah yeah or
they wouldn't go they would go watch it
is called a fanservice is that retro
fanservice
and you know the guys in directed him
and [ __ ] had no intention of they didn't
realize that maybe
women or girls would be watching that
[ __ ] it was just young guys so they just
targeted it right to them little did
they know girls were watching them too
well yeah but they didn't care it was
just you know they wanted to know who
would pay for tickets and who would rent
it VHS and before they had been a porn
of you know easy accessible porn that
you know kids are [ __ ] read that well
yeah see some boobs it's not only could
you see boobs but you also got to see
people get shopping yeah yeah it was a
fun time it is very funny to be there
now cuz I really liked like eighty
slasher movies and stuff like that it's
like yeah you can say they're you know
sexist or whatever but it's like they
were serious though yeah I never really
like took it all that seriously and
honestly I think it's better you know
nowadays it seems like it's more
accepted that women like horror as well
I feel like when I was growing up I mean
even a lot of my female friends and
stuff like that didn't like horror or
didn't like it as much I guess I don't
know I guess I was like kind of an
outlier in the sense that I'm like I was
like a horror geek I want to know like
see every single horror movie I Bought
Fangoria I have like the whole thing
like songs most girls wanted most I mean
most girls would go see a scary movie
like every now and then but it wasn't
like you know they wouldn't rent them
like they wouldn't they didn't like
super gory ones or anything like that I
feel like it's better like it's it's a
lot more accepted now that there are a
lot more women that are into horror that
write horror and stuff like that during
that first part of the [ __ ] 80s man
the Golden Age a horror man or there
were two genres that were just teenage
male dominated and that was horror
movies and [ __ ] heavy metal yeah soon
as Bon Jovi came out and heavy metal
started being marketed more towards
girls that was it I said [ __ ] this [ __ ]
through my [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
going gone boarded up the tree house no
girls allowed on it
[ __ ] it up I don't want him your girl
cooties all over my heavy-metal became
the net cuz I'm a cowboy
I mean I wasn't into metal but I liked
punk and I like other stuff so I liked
other like I guess male cigs saturated
of Duff it's just that you know girls
didn't listen to [ __ ] Judas Priest
Iron Maiden and they just did ya know
fate you know there's an and then the
ones that didn't listen to it you know
you didn't want anything to do with them
a lot of times that way like with girls
that were into horror to which it always
like it always kind of made me laugh
because even I was growing up like dudes
I would hear dudes talk and they'd be
like you know dudes were really into
horror
they'd always like want a girlfriend
that liked horror yeah but they didn't
actually want to hang out with a girl
than the guitar probably no they really
didn't yeah because it's it I don't know
I felt like they they wanted like
something that didn't exist yet super
super funny yeah super feminine
you didn't usually get maybe now he only
saw that in the movies that did that
yeah yeah I mean usually women that were
into horror back then working on boys
yeah tomboyish or geeky or you know not
super like cheerleader types I mean you
didn't really see that all that much
yeah so I feel like that's kind of what
they wanted and that just didn't exist I
don't think yeah it's kind of with girls
are into heavy metal during that era
tomboyish yeah you didn't look at my
girls do you I guess when they got a
little bit you know like I said though
you don't know it Bon Jovi [ __ ] happen
then they were wearing all this friends
jackets and fringe [ __ ] boots
yeah it's like a heavy metal started to
look up awful lot like country-western
to me it did there was a little surgery
after about 1986 yeah yeah what the [ __ ]
is this man see that's why I was glad I
was just into punk in new ways yeah and
like you for the beginning yeah got no
more to say about this yeah we've been
gone like half an hour but but yeah if
you have shudder this is definitely a
good one word see especially if you like
super gory you know there's
it's--there's Gor it's super fun it's
like I know everybody's like oh god
another zombie movie but really this one
is a good time
and I really really enjoyed it a lot
might watch it again actually just
because I thought it was so amusing and
I just I want to see the liposuction
thing and that because that went on I
thought it was really funny
what happened 175 Oh Melissa is talking
about GG I don't know he took my GG
who's got GG was see that you said gg
yeah a price it all kind of [ __ ] I say
[ __ ] never forget about it yeah he does
all I see stuff in the comments and then
[ __ ] laugh and then mention is
something I talked about I forgot all
about it yeah the shit's just off the
top of my head you know yeah so like
demons demons make me say it
yeah it's like they're it's they're
working through them yeah minutes later
you won't remember that the channel in
it you know I could do it on command and
I should have been a [ __ ] stand-up
comic that I get my ass beat fight
because I'd say crazy [ __ ] I don't know
about that because it's like you had all
those kind of older like comics and
stuff that yeah yes true people far as I
know they're rolling nobody got there
yeah I don't think that a lot of goons
I remember [ __ ] when I was a kid
Buddy Hackett be drunk drunk off his ass
saying crazy [ __ ] member buddy hi hey I
remember that man I don't remember
anything that he said though because
it's like that was kind of I was still a
kid then
yeah he's [ __ ] bizarre and then
there's just a lot of them from that
from from that 70s era that God Way was
saying all kinds of [ __ ] Rodney
Dangerfield said a lot of [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] and then you know what was funny is
I Mert I remembered how funny Eddie
Murphy stand-up was and so I went back
and listened to it more recently that's
just like it's just like normal [ __ ]
people say nowadays but back in the 80s
yeah that was real shocking back then
but you really listened to it now I feel
like nothing's shocking everybody talks
like that
I don't literally don't think there's a
single thing that you know which I don't
know in a way that's good in a way it's
bad I don't know
XANA de sayin indeed get me on ayahuasca
oh man in innocent demons talking
through [ __ ] Tom yes Richard Pryor
was good yeah I did yeah a lot of that
stuff wouldn't be allowed now dalire
delirious and stuff I went back sauce
made Murphy movie said you know the
Beverly Hills Cop one and two are really
good three sucked
golden child was good I liked it yeah
what else did I see recently they had a
minute
the vampire in Brooklyn vampire in
Brooklyn I liked that one
the 24 48 hours yeah it was okay I
didn't like as much as I liked - yeah
back in the day it was a little dry by
today's standards it was it wasn't as
funny as I mattered and not like and not
that it wasn't funny in that the jokes
fell flat but it wasn't as much of a
comedy as I remember they'd be yeah and
it wasn't really a comedy and it's
supposed to be like a real hard-boiled
cop flick but it's not really it's kind
of more like boring yeah did you notice
that yeah I did notice that act yeah
which was weird because like I said was
back in the day yeah like I said I
remembered it being a comedy yeah and
it's kind of not no I mean it has funny
[ __ ] in it but it's not like more like a
70s cop movie yeah it's it kind of
seemed like that
yeah but yeah so anyway you know you
guys any questions anything on you say
coming to America yeah oh yeah I gotta
get that one there's good they're making
a sequel to that yeah everybody heard
about that yeah it strategically deploy
a fan yeah yeah trying to remember the
name of that [ __ ] I think she was from
Ukraine that girl I can't I can see her
face but I can't think of what her name
is Svetlana something or other you know
it was like one of those but anyway yeah
that girl was [ __ ] skinny as a stick
with [ __ ] like GG the huge rack on
her she was and that was natural yeah
and
she was just some kind of supernatural
genetic [ __ ] anomaly really big in
Japan like they had guys producers in
Japan putting out a whole bunch of money
to do basically kind of like nude and
semi-nude 2 hour long videos of her that
only something like that would sell in
Japanese market but a lot of that stuff
ended up on the Internet and never
really didn't she never did any porn per
se and then she just retired she only
did it for a few years [ __ ] man if he
could just make money walking around
like a gauzy Beach yes with flashing
your tits around and not have to do porn
right it's basically what you remember
you remember I remember like god she was
18 19 something yeah yeah somebody uh
Oracle Munn asked him for y'all ravit
the happy deathday movies I think we did
on the when we still did the old matinee
show or he did at the theater we
reviewed a happy deathday to you this
the second one which I really liked and
then I don't think we've reviewed the
first one but we did watch it because we
watched it like on we've rented it
before we saw the second one which I'm
glad we did because I appreciated the
second one a lot more but I actually
really like this movies I like that
chick that's in it
she's um I can't remember name at the
moment but she's in the valley girl
remake which I heard was kind of
terrible I kind of want to watch it but
then I kind of don't I'd rather just
watch the original again like with
Nicolas Cage is it as a baby well baby
but you know it's like a 19 or 20 year
old guy um what's the title of this
movie this movie that we're talking
about right now
yummy yummy yeah it'll be on the it's
it's on the title thing and everything
yeah it's it's Belgian and came out last
year at South by Southwest yeah says I
love the happy deathday movies they were
actually really good second one wasn't
so much a horror movie it was kind of
more sci-fi but um you know nothing
wrong with that I actually had a good
time with him I thought they were really
good and really like creative alright so
we done with the yeah this review all
right so we will be back live streaming
our actual episode episode 202 in about
four and a half hours from now about
7:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time so if
you guys guess what I found that girl oh
you did yeah kidding don't don't get the
video do months I can actually just
that's her that's right I remember that
see that's kind of what the girl in the
movie look like like bill yeah build
wise you know what I mean
see if I can fast forward a I don't know
I don't remember what her name was
Oh
supernatural oh yeah somebody says dark
on I guess oh he says dark sci-fi I
thought you were talking about the show
on that Netflix it's called dark cuz I
was gonna say oh that's a really good
show that German I don't remember what
her name was
I'd let her give me an uppercut yeah so
we're gonna be back later on today so
everybody come and have a cocktail your
three or seven or however me dance up
drink now I know that girl's name by the
time we get back I'll look it up so I'll
remind you all right so we'll see you
guys in just a few hours and as always
thanks for dropping by